hello my name is Martin and this is my
mother really and we come from Brisbane
Australia and today we're very very
lucky to be sharing with you how
once-in-a-lifetime experience in the
wonderful winter city of mini so let's
have a look Oh mom look at this building
I can't believe it's 41 degrees Celsius
in the Australia right now so at least
we're lucky wearing the rain Oh mum
that's the awesome Keisha ok let's go
funny how it goes squeeze in the
building
we never see such beautiful church in
the world I feel I'm in heaven I feel
same Mary coming to me stop those were
real curtain when we go into this
challenge it's like coming into an old
cave in an old city like an old a sacred
magical cave oh yes this is um Germany
money traditional clothes well this is
very special difference if any clothes
shop was the names deer Deerling deer
DNA giggling yes we are gender big game
nice even I was young I always want to
dress like this
would you look great don't like the gym
is my mother I enjoy my holiday very
much yes yes and no wait like a friends
yes we're like friends while we're here
mom okay what's this is a righteous
museum adults music this is one of the
biggest Science Museum in the world when
I found on the Internet
we never really visited science museums
and I heard the deutsches museum is one
of the biggest and most bakit
spectacular museum in the world
thank God I'm not suffering from costa
verde
when I was in this cage I don't really
feel anything it's this it's it feels
like there's nothing inside but I can
see outside there's lights and there's
electricity and let's go get something
to eat I'm hungry this this is all
change and this is true no way coming
with this nice fat so we say goodbye to
0 but next time we have to bring grandma
here yes I should show the whole world
help you look for Munich is thank you
very much thank you anytime bye-bye